thanks after the best gift you've ever
received one that made you realize
someone perfectly understood what makes
you you you are smiling but the person
who gave you the gift was glowing is it
possible the gift give her experiences
greater happiness than the person
receiving Charles Darwin seemed to think
of generosity as this great threat to
his theory of natural selection it's as
if he thought the only way for us to
survive was by following our impulses
after all you and me we're wired with
our own sometimes selfish wants and
desires for a reason they keep us alive
so why do we still want to give
neuroscience has uncovered all these
wonderful little insights into why we
enjoy giving giving and receiving both
have this way of lighting up the
mesolimbic pathway that's part of the
brains pleasure and reward network
triggered by things like winning the
lottery enjoying a favorite food or
engaging in some of life's more exciting
activities so here's where giving has an
edge on receiving in a 2007 study
researchers found that giving money to
others release oxytocin and participants
brains but that didn't happen when
participants received money you see
oxytocin strengthens the bonds that make
us human and helps to ensure our
survival think for just a second about
everyone on your holiday gift list it's
this who's who of all the most important
people in your life what if sharing a
gift with the people we care about most
is the scientific key to the warm glow
we call holiday spirit a 2008 study
exploring how spending money on others
affects our happiness came to a very
interesting conclusion people who spent
money on someone else reported higher
levels of happiness than the
spent it on themselves giving to others
it's almost as if we're hardwired to
make others feel good
so go ahead share your gift